[Musique]
cette aventure elle est née de la folie
d'un homme cet homme qui se trouve juste
à côté de moi qui parmi les nombreuses
idées qui peut avoir a eu celle-ci m'a
proposé de trouver un moyen d'allier
l'utile à l'agréable de poursuivre notre
mandat demeure en étant utile quelque
part la société et à travers une belle
cause donc là deux villes pour devis une
opération qui consistera donc à sauver
deux enfants que c'est la première
action on peut vous dire que qu'il y en
aura d'autres
[Musique]
oui cette fédérer assez largement et
donner cette envie de s'engager aussi
pour des causes humanitaires notre
engagement politique il est ce qu'il est
il a son utilité évidemment que on est
pleinement engagé dans cet engagement là
excusez du la répétition mais en tout
cas c'est vrai que on voulait apporter
une petite chose supplémentaire et vivre
une aventure humaine qui va notamment se
dérouler au Wolf Marathon des Sables
[Musique]
on va partir pour entre 100 et 120 km de
course dans le désert des Canaries il y
aura beaucoup de sable évidemment il y
aura du vent on sait qu'on va avoir mal
on sait qu'on va souffrir mais on le
fait pour la bonne cause donc ouais on
va partir sur plusieurs jours de course
on sera en bivouac le soir on aura pas
de douche on va manger notre petite
gamelle de yoshylisé donc on part à
l'aventure mais on le fait vraiment avec
cœur et on le sait on sait pourquoi on
va le faire
l'idée c'est effectivement de récolter
24000 euros pour pouvoir sauver deux
enfants 12000 euros par opération c'est
le reste à charge à travers mes Sénats
chirurgicardiaques et donc 24000 euros
c'est bien la cible deux enfants un
enfant par ville et ils seront
accueillis chaque enfant sera accueilli
dans l'une de nos villes
[Musique]